[Music]
thank you
hey you guys what's going on everybody
hope you're having a good Sunday so far
uh Tom just got back from the bar so I
don't know what went down over there
because he hasn't been around he hasn't
been home that long just normal [ __ ]
we're gonna do Pulp Fiction
[ __ ] great movie saw it last night
yeah I've seen it several times but I
actually haven't seen it for several
years I saw it a bunch of times I
haven't seen it for like 20 years
probably yeah yeah it's a good movie
Louie sent us that one as well along
with the Reservoir Dogs back in the
collection yeah it's um
yeah movie held up it held up it's
actually better now than it was
yeah it's me it has yes surprisingly
even those came out all the way back in
199 [ __ ] four when I was only four
years out of high school for Christ's
sake
um it really has not dated at all no I
think it's gotten better I think it has
as well
um like I said I'm pretty sure I think I
saw in the theater when it came out
um and I've seen it like I said
subsequently many times since then and I
always like like it better each time but
watching it again last night I just you
know after not a long time not seeing it
I'm really familiar with it but it
always just like every time I watch it
it always like it Delights me Anew you
know yeah just because it's just it's so
funny and it's just like full of energy
yeah and it's I don't know it's just
like such a great I love the structure
of it you know energy that's a good way
to that's a good way yeah it's a very I
mean you can tell this was like a
passion project this was something
everybody was really enthusiastic about
like nobody looks like they're phoning
it in nobody looks like they're not
having a good time everybody just looks
like they put 110 into this yeah and
it's like watching Four movies and
they're called kind of interwoven with
each other and they're jumping around
it's good it's good well the initial
idea I don't know if you know but
Quentin Tarantino wrote this with um his
friend Roger Avery and what they were
planning on doing initially was you know
the um the Italian uh horror Anthology
movie uh Black Sabbath that has Morris
Carlock it's like three stories that's
what he was planning to do he was gonna
do one like that but it was going to be
called black mask and it was going to be
three stories
like based on like old like crime like
Pulp magazines right so that's kind of
what they started to do so actually
Roger Avery his friend wrote the gold
watch thing like about you know the
boxer and all of that kind of stuff and
they kind of want to do because Quentin
Tarantino and it's like funny that like
I said when we were talking about
Reservoir Dogs he's not the same but the
first person that like you know that
shot a movie and they showed it like out
of order I mean now it's like really
common like a lot of people do it it was
a lot rarer back in the 90s to do it I
think it made like a really big impacts
that it was shot out of context with
that it was you know not in uh you know
not in chronological order
and he said that he wanted it to be more
like he's like you know novelists do
that all the time where you have like
three different stories going on for
example but they're all kind of like
interrelated they don't have to
necessarily be in chronological order
and a lot of people too have pointed out
that particularly this movie and
Reservoir Dogs it almost plays more like
a real good album than like a narrative
story yeah you know what I mean which I
kind of feel like that was on purpose
like especially as
integrated as music is into his films I
feel like he wants to do it like he's
more interested in I guess like the
dramatic impact the Thematic impact of
it rather than like showing things
happening like in a yeah the way they
happened in real life because he'll show
you the end first and then stop it and
then go back and then show you how it
got to that and then and even the end
that he showed you wasn't the end and
there was a resolution to the end yeah
later on that's kind of what the movie
is all about but it doesn't really
matter it's just you watch it and you
have a good time
and you get to know the characters in
their stories and what happens to them
and even as important as a character as
a character may be
they still kind of have [ __ ] like
a [ __ ] up and like uh [ __ ]
um
the one character that that uh [ __ ]
oh John Travolta plays he's a main
character yeah Vincent Vega yeah Vincent
Vega and he dies because he forgot to
because he was taking a crap yeah well
if you noticed that God if you notice
throughout the film yeah every time he's
in the bathroom like bad [ __ ] happens
yeah you know what I mean because like
he was in the bathroom like when uh
pumpkin and honey bunny started like
healing up the diner yeah uh you know he
was in the bathroom or actually there
was another guy in the bathroom like
when they came in that apartment to like
[ __ ] with those dudes about taking the
briefcase it's like so every time he's
in the bathroom yeah something bad oh
and he was in the bathroom at uh Mia
Wallace's house when yeah Uma Thurman's
character oh dude yeah going to the
bathroom was his weakness
I guess that likes the worst possible
time
because he mostly he went to the
bathroom you know and [ __ ] he made it
until the one time he goes to the
bathroom and he comes out and the dude
he was there to kill who's a boxer he
left his [ __ ] suppressed Mac 10. I I
don't think that was his I think that
was um I think that was Ving rhames's
that was Marcellus Wallace's maybe
because they were both supposed to be
they were supposed to be there but see
when because when Bruce Willis is when
Butch left the apartment he sees
Marcellus walking across the street
right that's how they kind of get back
like they see each other he had left to
go get some donuts or some [ __ ] like
that and he left his gun oh okay so that
actually wasn't that wasn't Vincent's oh
no I had thought that too but then like
when I was thinking about it I was like
no that was actually marcellus's gun
because he had gone out to like to go
get coffee and donuts because he was
crossing the street like so I think like
the the cool thing about the movie too
is that it all hinges on little uh
coincidences like that which kind of
goes into I guess like the greater theme
it's not a super deep movie or anything
like that but it does kind of go into
like a greater thing of like things
happening by chance or you know and
there's that whole thing about
Redemption and uh divine intervention
you know particularly with Samuel L
Jackson's character Sam Jackson [ __ ]
knocks it out of the park in this movie
this is
this is the movie that brought Sam
Jackson to my notice you know I noticed
him because of this movie when he came
out it was like I didn't realize he was
the same dude from coming from America
remember that he was in Coming to
America yeah very briefly it was like a
cami yeah he was he he robbed
mcdougall's that's right yeah yeah he
was in it for like 30 seconds 30 seconds
yeah but this movie kind of in my mind
cemented him as a character I was like
God damn you know that's a cool dude
well like I said he want he was supposed
to be well he auditioned for Reservoir
Dogs but he didn't get it and so then
like he ended up being he'd been in
stuff before this but I think this was
kind of his start the thing about this
movie is that I mean the cast of this I
had just forgotten house like every
[ __ ] is in this and this was it's you
know hard to imagine now too because Uma
Thurman was like so famous but that she
had been in other things before this too
but this was definitely her the movie
that catapulted her onto the A-list for
sure yeah and Bruce Willis
um he was probably the most famous
[ __ ] in this at the time and him
being in it actually I think that's what
helps the movie get like kind of
worldwide distribution because he was so
bankable like from his action movies and
stuff all over the world up because of
all that yeah
um so I think initially in the initial
um version of the script I think the
boxer character was supposed to be like
a young guy like an up-and-coming guy
but when they decided to have like Bruce
Willis in it they decided to make him
kind of like a little bit older like
over the hill
I guess for a boxer like for any kind of
athlete it's probably like older you
know what I mean yeah but I mean
this just like what I just because I've
been watching like you know other
people's like breakdowns analysis and
stuff like that it's like this movie is
just so iconic that there's even I'd
actually never heard this but there's
actually like all kind of fan theories
you know the very famous
um you know McGuffin of the of the
briefcase the briefcase did they never
show you what's in there yeah uh the
most as far as I know the most common uh
fan theory about that is that what's in
there is Marcellus Wallace's soul
well because because of those scenes
where he has like the Band-Aid on the
back of his head and like they never say
what that is and I guess there's a thing
where it's like when they take your soul
out like we sell your sell your soul to
the devil they take it out the back of
your head yeah in reality he just like
cut his head shaving it like for the
role
and then Quentin Tarantino likes the
Band-Aid so much that he just kept like
focusing on it yeah well I I never
really took it as that watching the
movie I always thought it was either
some kind of drugs or gold but it
couldn't have been gold because
gold would have weighed a lot that's
what I was thinking initially I would
have thought well it's gold bars but it
would have been too heavy to like carry
around because they were just carrying
it around I thought it was some kind of
drugs they're like a [ __ ] a whole
briefcase filled with
cocaine or something you know it was
something like it's definitely a
McGuffin but you know like yeah yeah
we're good but that's why I like that
they never showed what was in it you
know what I mean Richard Brown said not
Tarantino's ego no I don't think anyone
well you know you might be the first one
to say that but that was kind of like
the most common Tarantino's in this
movie and that [ __ ] can't act I know
actually Robert Rodriguez directed him
in that scene you can't but what got
better as he went on he can't but I
don't know like for for that role like
it works it doesn't bother me yeah but
yeah he's not an actor no well as you
notice like he he was in he did get
better yeah but he was in his movies
less and less like his time went on so
it seems like his ego wasn't that big he
wasn't like Neil Breen level or anything
where he's just like putting himself as
a god-like figure a god-like figure
who's the lead
everybody's like stick with
screenwriting and directing and those
are those are your strengths acting not
so much but I don't know I do I do like
him in this movie but he's not
believable no I mean it's very very
obvious that that's just Quentin
Tarantino there's a lot and I'm like Yay
I'm in a movie you know there's a lot of
[ __ ] in the movie that's cool that it's
not believable okay like well yeah Like
the Wolf okay
they call they call Harvey Keitel and
it's the wolf right and hit and he's the
special man to help them because they
accidentally killed the [ __ ] dude or
Marvin Marvin by accident all right they
need him to show up to tell them to
clean the car
I'm like I'm watching this [ __ ] and I'm
going oh like Jenny hold on did he just
tell them to clean the car yeah they had
this special [ __ ] had to they
had to call this special [ __ ]
out out of the Woodman the mafia had to
come and show up and tell them to clean
the car pretty much and put quilts in
and put quilts
that anybody would have come up with
that [ __ ] put the dude in the truck
clean the car hide the upholstery okay
well now I I will note that he did have
the connection for Monster Joe's
junkyard yeah where you go and dispose
of the bodies you know what I mean which
maybe the low level hit men don't have
that because I kind of feel like Harvey
keitel's like you know Winston wolf he's
kind of like higher up so he's got all
those connections it was still hilarious
I know but like I said but that's it's
not a good scene I mean the thing about
the movie though is it's supposed to be
like a black comedy like it's not really
supposed to be realistic the thing that
I like about it that I think a lot of
people responded to
was that much like in Reservoir Dogs so
we were talking about that before how
it's about a heist but you never see the
heist
this movie is kind of like that but like
writ large it's kind of like all of the
big things that happen in the movie like
a lot of the kind of uh a lot of the
heists a lot of the major things that
are referred to like for example Bruce
Willis's character like killing the
other boxer like in the fight they don't
show it they just like show like the
aftermath so it's almost kind of like
it's almost kind of like you're just
watching the like fringes of the life
like around big events that would
normally be like big set pieces in other
movies you know what I'm saying it's
kind of like he's just showing how
you know like I said in most other
movies it would be just like these big
actions that this guy like killed a guy
boxing or this guy did that you know
this this these people like took the you
know those kids in the apartment that
took marcellus's briefcase like [ __ ]
like that they would show that stuff but
this they just all show like the
aftermath or like the [ __ ] that's going
around around the outside of it and it's
like they show enough though right right
right sure enough I mean Zed and the
gint and the [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] man that
[ __ ] is awesome
you okay you're okay man no man I'm far
from [ __ ]
Ving Rhames being rames [ __ ] knocked
it out of the park everybody in the
movie [ __ ] knocks it out of the park
it is it does have a a special Gestalt
to this movie I mean it's it's just like
everybody in this movie is [ __ ] going
like yeah this is this is a good movie
let's [ __ ] knock this [ __ ] out of the
park I mean it's just
it's a fun movie to watch I mean The
Ensemble is amazing like I said this is
single-handedly yeah uh brought back the
career of John Travolta yeah it did
which I mean yeah because I mean you
know obviously he was real big in the
70s and he was still in stuff like in
the 80s and stuff but he was more like
in kind of like shitty ass movies yeah
and this like made him an A-list star
again yeah and like I said it made a
huge summer action movies after this
right it's like it made a huge
difference out of uh Uma Thurman
it was just kind of like oh funny fact
about the whole um that whole basement
uh rape scene there was that originally
um Tarantino wanted the music playing
over that scene To Be My Sharona
which I don't know that might have
changed it totally a little bit cool I
will I guess they couldn't
um they didn't they ended up not using
it because that movie Reality Bites came
out the same year and that had a big
scene of you know the girls in the
convenience store like dancing to that
song and also apparently one of the
members of The Knack had since become a
born-again Christian and was not like
super happy about their about it being
over like over like an anal rape scene
which you know
um you know but uh I was watching
another thing too about how many um
how many instances of the of the f word
of the word [ __ ] in this it was
something like
258 or something like that it was like
some amazing amount I guess I didn't
really notice all that much because like
I said I swear a lot too so it's just
kind of like another word to me but
apparently when this came out I mean
this pretty much immediately because we
were talking about this a little bit
when we were talking about Reservoir
Dogs too but about how that like had a
big impact but I mean obviously because
this was so much more successful like
mainstream successful this had a massive
massive massive impact on Hollywood just
across the board I mean a lot of people
that were around at that time I remember
being around at that time and people
were just like it was just like a
[ __ ] like a cultural Juggernaut you
know what I mean it's not only was
immediately like one of the coolest
movies ever but it's easily I don't even
think anybody would argue with you if he
said it's the most uh influential film
in the 90s I mean as soon as this came
out like there was [ __ ] ripoff films
American Crime films British crime films
there's like a whole sub-genre of movies
that were supposed to be like this movie
I mean it just came out and it just blew
the [ __ ] doors off
and it also changed a lot of the because
remember I was saying before like before
indie films like some of them sometimes
got nominated for Oscars or got like a
lot of mainstream success or something
but not to the extent that it happened
after
Pulp Fiction and there was a thing too
where like A-list movie stars would go
would now go back and forth like they'd
be like in some big tentpole movie and
then they'd be like in a little Indie
movie and it wasn't as odd anymore it
was I kind of feel like it was more
delineated like before this movie came
out because you have this movie cost
eight and a half million dollars to make
and made over 200 million dollars and it
won the Palm Door at can the highest
thing like it got pretty much almost
Universal praise like immediately like
right out of the gate got nominated for
a whole bunch of oscars uh very famously
lost to Forrest Gump of all things
which is shitty because so because Pulp
Fiction came out the same day as another
awesome movie that should have won at
the Oscars the Shawshank Redemption both
of these movies came out the same
[ __ ] day
and they both got nominated for best
picture and they both lost to Forrest
Gump which
of course comes a good movie but I liked
it at the time but it didn't age as well
it didn't age very well
um it it really didn't and it doesn't
hold I mean this movie absolutely holds
up it does not seem
this movie does not seem to me like it
came out in the 90s it seems like it
could have come out yesterday to be
honest with you and um last time I saw I
saw Shawshank Redemption I kind of had
the same
feeling about that like it doesn't seem
dated at all the thing about Forrest
Gump though is I think that because it
relies so much on special effects
because like the whole you know gimmick
of it was oh look we're putting you know
Forest Gump into like all of these big
you know historical events
and so you know it was 1994 so it's like
the special effects were good for the
time but they don't really look that
great anymore and it's just so
it's so trickly and it's just so
boomery you know
um in a way it was a lot more x-gen yeah
this one is a lot I mean I don't think
anybody would argue this was a lot
cooler so I think like a lot of people
were mad that Forrest Gump like beat out
this movie because this movie was
obviously way way way way more
influential on filmmaking as an art form
yeah it's got a lot of fake gangster
[ __ ] in it but it is cool uh it's it's a
fun movie it knows what it is it calls
itself what it is it's pulpy it's just
pulp pulp gangster fiction
it's a great flick I Like It Fun
I mean somebody's in the comment section
[ __ ] talking about
the cringe some of the cringy [ __ ]
that's in it uh you know what I mean
[ __ ] Tarantino in his house playing a
fake [ __ ] character talking about
dead [ __ ] storage and [ __ ] just [ __ ]
it's just that [ __ ] went off forever it
was funny okay you could not do that
today all right but it was funny because
you knew it was crazy [ __ ]
yeah I think that [ __ ] back then that's
why I allow it because it's like it was
supposed to be a throwback to another
era right in the day that it came out I
mean he is homage
all over the place I mean there's just
like little like if you're because
Quentin Tarantino knows more about like
old movies [ __ ] even that whole the
famous speech you know the Biblical
quote that Samuel L Jackson's character
gives which is actually not exactly from
the Bible it's from an old like Kung Fu
movie it's from a sunny Chiba movie
that's where he got that from is that
from the Bible yeah and there's there's
some just classic [ __ ] [ __ ] Samuel L
Jackson's character is talking about
that's it I'm gonna retire I'm gonna
walk the earth and just get get involved
in Adventures like Kane from cooking
[ __ ] John Travolta's character that
he's playing what's what's his name
again what's John Travolta's character
again yeah Vincent is like dude walking
around living [ __ ] having an
adventure that's a bomb you're talking
about being a bum yeah
uh it's homeless beat about and he's
like no you're gonna call it whatever
but then that's exactly what it would be
yeah
bombs walk the earth
okay pretty much [ __ ] that's what
bombs are doing walking the Earth have
an Adventures
it's just an awesome movie you know I
mean all of their conversations like I
said I know why you know Tarantino gets
such a great I mean I you know he gets
like so many accolades like for
screenwriting and stuff and I know that
Roger Avery like um helped him write the
screenplay like they co-wrote the
screenplay on this one as well but I
mean he really does have a great [ __ ]
way with dialogue yeah you know what I
mean I mean that's really his strength
and like just bringing characters to
life you know what I mean like I said
they're not realistic necessarily but
they're Larger than Life you know what I
mean and they're meant to be that way
um Zach says I still think my favorite
movie from 1994 was shallow grave oh
[ __ ] that's a great [ __ ] movie we
should probably review that at some
point you've probably never seen it
happen oh it's good I used to have it on
DVD but I don't know what happened to it
actually
um yeah grave there's this is a good
analogy he says this did to movies what
Nirvana did to Rocky yeah that's a good
thing yeah and it happened like right I
mean Nirvana that was earlier that was
1991 but it was like pretty much the
same thing where it was just it it was
one thing and it just changed everything
it busted the floodgates
you've busted the floodgates open it's
like crashing through the [ __ ] glass
door
yeah and they're like okay we can do we
can do whatever now yeah but it was uh
it was a cool flick and in a time you
couldn't believe you were seeing it it
was it had changed the Paradigm it did
and uh you go back and watch it and it
is still [ __ ] it is a cool movie it's
fun it's still hilarious like all of it
is still like funny yeah
now later on he started doing movies I
thought were just ridiculous they didn't
change a paradigm but he got but
Tarantino came back to kind of his
senses and started to do [ __ ] that was
also real cool
um but this movie in its place and time
did it did Sharon change the paradigm
and I still think it holds up I mean
watching it again last night I had a
[ __ ] it's better now than it was like
re-watching it and it's it to me it
seems like it is not dated at all
um it's still funny it still seems very
fresh there's something about it you
watch it now and you're like you missed
this in modern movies you're like yeah
yeah this is the way well and this kind
of happened you know this happened with
Nirvana too since we're going with that
analogy is that you know it ever it
comes out and like it's this big you
know iconic moment and like then ever
but then everybody starts ripping it off
yeah and then after a while you're so
sick of all the rip-offs and everything
like that that it's like you go back and
watch the original thing and it doesn't
seem all that special anymore because
now you've seen like all the things that
were pale imitations of it yeah but not
this one though no not that and like and
I like Lion X Warrior said guy Richie uh
the British filmmaker yeah uh has been
ripping off Tarantino style for decades
yeah I kind of feel like a lot of
American filmmakers did too you like in
the wake of this I was even reading like
on Wikipedia there was like some film
Scholars or film teachers or something
and they said [ __ ] man like the year
after Pulp Fiction came out it's like
every student film we got was like a
Pulp Fiction like Pastiche you know what
I mean like they had uh elements of that
and everyone was like ripping it off
but
um I think the the British in particular
because they have such a long tradition
of like crime films and stuff I kind of
feel like they jumped on that train and
like wrote it hard because and some of
those movies were really good actually
the British ones but you know this was
like kind of you know like I said
Reservoir Dogs are kind of like the
first one but
I kind of feel like maybe a lot of
people didn't see Reservoir Dogs until
after this got hugely famous and got
nominated for Oscars and Golden Globes
and everything like that and just made
this massive impact you know what I mean
Grand there says question would Tom ever
ask one of his friends to be good
company to Jenny if he went out of town
for a few days
no I never asked Steve to do it Steve is
trying to [ __ ] get up in it
I know better
none of my friends and [ __ ] beef no
hell no they're all predatory back in
the day yeah yeah but we'd have to trade
if he had if it was a trade if it was a
trade you know if he had a real hot wife
or girlfriend or something like okay
well we're gonna trade for a while you
know then that might be different but
you know everybody would have to be up
on it you know everybody had to know
what to do with
and how do where do you come down on the
whole foot massage situation because for
massage no foot massage is intimate I
think you shouldn't be massaging
people's feet see I kind of think that
too it's like I know that they were
having this whole discussion and it's
like they both they were good there were
good points on each side but it didn't
happen according to her well no all
right but I'm just saying just from a
from a theoretical massage and feet
yeah that's a little bit
and I thought that was funny where like
where like Samuel L Jackson Jewels
that's his character's name he was all
like he he thought that uh Marcellus was
overreacting
like by throwing that guy out of the
fourth floor window for massaging his
wife's feet but then
um you know Vincent makes the very uh
Salient point he's like well uh would
you massage another man's feet he's like
I'm kind of tired you know I could use a
foot massage right now then he wouldn't
do it so he's like God it just kind of
like proved his point I was like yeah
exactly it is kind of like
I'm the foot [ __ ] master and they
were obviously lying those characters
were obviously alive
well yeah well that's what was funny but
I've given millions of foot massages
[ __ ] line but you know that's
something that Tarantino would do his
[ __ ] foot fetish ass in his in his
movies his characters would also be all
in defeat probably or at least lie about
being in defeat but you know
people are going like well he's Terrance
gonna rip [ __ ] off yeah but he knows it
well and he's not he's making he's not
making a secret about it either I mean
and I'm fine with this stuff and he
likes old stuff
he'll [ __ ] kind of rehash it and
reboot everything I mean he's very in
interviews he's very open about hey I
got this idea from this movie and I got
this idea I mean like the dance scene
and this like he got from uh I think the
movie Kiss Me Deadly like he like I said
the whole concept for the movie came
from Black Sabbath the horror Anthology
so it's like he's not making any secret
about it which like I said that's fine
with me that's fine with me
when Tarantino's on he's on yeah yeah
and it's off I don't like him but when
he's on his own
yeah I mean some is like you know like
everything else like his movies vary in
quality but he's made a lot so it's just
kind of like but watching this one again
last night I remember really liking this
one like I said I saw it several times
like back in the 90s and 2000s but I
hadn't seen it for a very long time but
watching it again I was like I forgot
what a great this is a great [ __ ]
movie I mean I forgot what a great movie
it's up there with Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood yeah I mean just like the I
love the narrative structure of it I
just love uh the character interactions
like the dialogue I just everything
about it is appealing and like I said it
just has so much energy to it all the
characters are appealing and funny and
it's just like a good time like watching
and it's long it's like two and a half
hours but it doesn't seem like it
because you're just having such a good
time hanging out with these people yeah
you know what I mean and that's kind of
the way Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
was yeah I had a blast with that movie
too that's also really long actually it
might be longer than Pulp Fiction now
that I'm thinking about it but you don't
really mind because you like watching it
yeah I think we didn't we said we saw
that in the theater twice didn't we yeah
and I got the Blu-ray I think that one's
almost three hours yeah but I didn't
mind that at all either because like I
said I don't the only reason that I
would have an issue with a movie being
long is if it was didn't need to be that
long or if it was like boring or
something like that but when it's
hanging out with people that are
interesting and you actually kind of
want to hang out with the people then it
just kind of seems like you're hanging
out with your friends or whatever you
know what I mean or you're just hanging
out with interesting people so it
doesn't seem like it's taking that long
of a Time Tarantino's zanious movie that
I'm that I'm still on board with would
have been like Death Proof Death Proof
is pretty [ __ ] zany yeah but I can
still watch it it's a good movie yeah
I'd rather take this though I take this
one or um
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood I mean I
think once upon a time in Hollywood this
is a masterpiece but once upon a time in
Hollywood is also a massive I think
those two are his best movies yeah
um I would like to re-watch Jackie Brown
although I'm pretty sure you haven't
seen that I don't think I've seen that
it's good but the thing about it it's
actually Jackie Brown is really good but
I think it's based on a novel I think
it's isn't it based on Elmore Leonard
novel maybe can somebody like correct me
of that I thought it was so it's not his
original
creation so he doesn't have quite the
same investment in it I guess as he
would like in his own screenplay but I
still remember liking it a lot like
seeing Tarantino like you know kind of
interpreting somebody else's work but
that's another one that I've been
wanting to re-watch because I haven't
seen that one in a really long time
um you know but I mean oh yeah I mean
Pulp Fiction and Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood are and Reservoir Dogs are his
best ones the other ones
um I like to varying degrees
and we should probably do like I said
some of the ones that he wrote the
screenplays for like True Romance and um
he wrote the screenplay for uh what the
[ __ ] is that movie with um
with [ __ ] Woody Harrelson in that
minute oh um yeah oh my God I just
totally blanked uh Natural Born Killer
thank you yeah man getting old socks you
guys
no we got a lot of stuff going around in
our heads yeah a lot of movies and
[ __ ] a lot of shows grafter says we
used to have a saying you can trust a
fellow cop with your life but never
leave your lunch or your girlfriend
alone with him
man he'll even steal your lunch that's
pretty low yeah donuts and [ __ ]
sandwiches and apples yeah doesn't I
feel like every workplace has one person
that will steal people's lunches yeah
well they're not eating I'm who does
that their refrigerator is [ __ ] empty
apparently a lot of people do that
because there's always one [ __ ]
that does it like at every workplace
I've ever worked at and it's like we
never could like Fair it out who it was
yeah but I was like man that is like
that is the lowest of the world you
don't steal somebody's lunch okay I mean
you don't steal her girlfriend either
but I'm just saying uh Daniel Rowling
said frosted cinnamon Pop-Tarts are the
[ __ ] and also deadly apparently yeah I
think those were actually they were
off-brand Pop-Tarts I don't even think
they were actual foods that he put in
the movie where he put the I didn't
notice the Pop-Tarts in the thing like I
love them like while Vincent was in the
bathroom and they popped out and that's
what scared him and he ended up shooting
him see but they were the they were the
store brand they weren't even like
Pop-Tarts you know what I mean
uh
Ben says the only uh good movie
Tarantino made apart from Pulp Fiction
was the quick and the dead fight me well
I don't want to fight I don't remember
that one but I don't think I saw that
one actually
uh granther said the only thing dated is
a White Guy saying the n-word over and
over that was then wouldn't be accepted
now yeah and it was dated Dan though it
was dated then that's what yeah I would
argue that like even back then people
were just kind of like okay you know
what I mean so it's so that's kind of
like but that's the reason why it works
because it's like supposed to be cringy
yeah I kind of feel like you know what I
mean like he's trying to be
terribly cool and not really succeeding
in it yeah but it's just kind of like I
don't know it's a very self-aware
performance and I think that's the only
thing that keeps it from
being
you know what I mean yeah
he's trying to be cool it's just not
cool and this well yeah he's a nerd but
I think he's a nerd he's aware he knows
that a nerd yeah I mean he wears that
badge with prize it's kind of like a
Stephen King trying to be in his own
movies I I mean that mother Stephen King
should not be in his own [ __ ] movie
hey I'm gonna I'll go to bat for Creep
Show yeah The Lonesome Death of Jordy
barrel and uh a lot of people don't like
that I thought he was [ __ ] great in
that like playing just like a dumb
Quinton his nerdy ass tries to show up
in a hardcore gangster movie that he
wrote okay and he's trying it's just
it's cringy it's [ __ ] candy
and you're supposed to I think supposed
to go man but you know that that's
that's what he was trying but like I
said I'm pretty sure that he was aware
that that's how it would be perceived
and that was like I think that's like
part of the joke well his movies he's
making movies that are supposed to be B
movies right it's supposed to be right
they're very selfish he's supposed to be
basing his movies on B movies right it's
a it's a b movie based on other B movies
that's how he gets away yeah that's kind
of the [ __ ] that you'd see in the movie
based on B movies and like I said I
think he gets away with
just the whole entire structure of his
movies and stuff like that too just
because he's very open about all the
stuff that he's homaging like I said
he's not trying to pretend that he's
some big genius that came up with this
that and the other thing he's saying no
I got this from that movie because I
loved that when I was a kid and I got
this from this movie it's like you know
what I mean he loves that [ __ ] and he
just wears it on his sleeves this movie
solidified the cool of Sam Jackson it
just it definitely he's the coolest
thing in the [ __ ] movie every scene
he's I mean he's so [ __ ] great yeah
he's so [ __ ] great and uh and in a
weird way [ __ ] John Travolta's cool
as [ __ ] in this movie too he's very cool
is not really a cool dude in real life
but I don't think no
because Sam Jackson is probably much
cooler in real life but well I can't
imagine Sam Jackson not to be yeah
that's so bad this these movies made
Samuel L Jackson
do you know that in this movie he was
supposed to have a big ass afro
yeah it was funny we were watching me
and Jenny were looking at his hair and I
was laughing look at his hair his
[ __ ] hair was kind of like a [ __ ]
mullet it was well it's a Jerry curl
it's like a Jerry curl Molly and his
[ __ ] was cringy then it was cringy then
apparently the story I heard yeah was
that originally he was supposed to have
a big ass afro that was what Tarantino
uh wanted because he was you know he's
homaging like black exploitation movies
because he was a big fan of black
exploitation movies
so I don't know if this is true but the
story I heard was that they sent one of
the like prop people or something like
that who was apparently white as [ __ ]
out to get some Afro wigs and they came
back with like a Jerry curl situation
Tarantino was kind of bad being like
what the [ __ ] is this all about this
isn't an afro yeah but then like when
Sam Jackson put it on he's like no this
is good he's like and tarantee was like
yeah you're right that is good yeah well
because it's like a [ __ ]
Afro-American version of a [ __ ]
mullet okay well because Sam Jackson
pointed out that he's like I think was
it um man [ __ ] who was it that was like
real big at that time was it I don't
wanna I wanna say it was maybe NWA or
somebody like that and one of them had
like some Jerry curl again
so so it was it was that kind of thing
so he was just like no it's this is
gonna work you know what I mean it'll be
better than like having a big and I
think it does because that hairstyle
like as cringe as it looks like he pulls
it off yeah
I don't think anybody else would have
but because it's Samuel L Jackson like
what was the best part of the movies
when they show up to the [ __ ] white
boys houses the ones that tried to steal
the briefcase and they go what time is
it and he goes it's 7 45 it's not time
this is we'll wait because there was a
time like I said yeah let's hang back
and then and then this hang back and
then they [ __ ] talk to each other and
go okay let's go get into character they
gotta get into character to go in there
in the [ __ ] good in here and kill
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] it's it's a
great scene and uh be probably a lot of
Truth in it probably a lot of Truth in
it eating that guy's Kahuna Burger
yeah he just shoots that one dude for
landing on the couch and he calls him
Flock of Seagulls yeah yeah
which like all the [ __ ]
I think that's why again I I think
that's why this works and I know this is
this may be gonna sound like out of left
field but I think that's why stuff like
Mystery Science Theater is still funny
all these years later because all of
their references that they made were old
back then like when they made them so
they don't really date the same way as
you know like for example a movie that
came out in the 90s that was making
references to very 90s things and like
now you're just like oh Jesus you know
what I mean but I remember that but if
you're referring back to like [ __ ] from
like the [ __ ] you know turn of the
century or like the 50s or the 60s or
something like that that's not going to
date necessarily because you know you're
referring to like older [ __ ] and they
asked the black dude remember that
[ __ ] why don't you tell us somebody
was in the bathroom come on let's go
he's going with them and they're friends
with him and then they accidentally
shoot him it's just but it's just it's
just some funny [ __ ]
and that and that scene was apparently
supposed to be different too uh I heard
that initially they weren't just like
supposed to shoot him in the face and
like blow his head off like happens at a
movie Marvin that character
um originally in the script they were
just gonna shoot him in the throat and
it didn't kill him right away and then
like later on they decided oh well we're
gonna have to like he's gonna die so
we're gonna put him out of his misery
but apparently
um John Travolta argued he's like well I
think that that would make our
characters less sympathetic like just
shooting him in the head like while he
was still alive
um so he's like I I don't know if John
Travolta recommended that or if the
actor that played Marvin recommended
that like because I've heard two stories
but they and they said plus it would be
like way funnier like in a [ __ ] up
kind of black comedy kind of way if um
you know they just accidentally like
blew his head off in the [ __ ] and just
the whole like the way that uh Vincent
and Jules like [ __ ] at each other while
they're cleaning the car yeah it just
[ __ ] cracks me up like Sam Jackson
like in the backseat like picking bits
of brain and like skull off the [ __ ] I
just thought the [ __ ] was fun that they
have to [ __ ] call Mr wolf over to
tell them to clean the car yeah I'm
gonna [ __ ] what's his name Mr Big I'm
gonna send this guy down for him to send
the wolf and he shows up he basically
tells me okay clean the car basically we
just tell him to clean the car
and that's [ __ ] that
we're gonna put some of this [ __ ] there
and then we're gonna put
that which normally I guess you wouldn't
have had to do if it wasn't like the
middle of the day but you know what I
mean yeah I mean that whole scene is
just [ __ ] hysterical like there's a I
can't think really I can't think of like
a single scene in this that isn't like
iconic or hasn't been like parodied like
all over the [ __ ] place I mean the
cultural impact that this movie had is
just yeah
it's it's really like hard to overstate
you need a special gangster to show up
to tell you to clean the car though that
[ __ ] and I love that he shows up and
he's like all you know just there with
this like coffee pot and he has his hot
girlfriend who's 20 years younger like
he had his tuxedo on still because it
looked like they were was he at an
auction or like a gambling like what was
it I don't remember what it was because
at first like I caught I thought he was
in a hotel yeah there was like but they
I think they were doing like um like a
gambling party or like a poker party or
something like that it's like some kind
of fancy like a James Bond kind of
situation so because he had like a
tuxedo on like it had gone on all night
and then he gets the phone call like he
has to he's asking for coffee
[Laughter]
all this stuff about like the really
good coffee that he did he's like yeah
of course it's good coffee yeah
[Laughter]
I let my wife buy it it's [ __ ] yeah
Ben says uh it adds realism most of the
criminals involved in gangs like this
are really really dumb yeah
well like I said I kind of feel like
this is because they're just kind of
showing them as just like kind of
regular work and shlubs you know what I
mean it's like they're not
they're not like super cool but in the
in the way that they're not cool they
end up being kind of cool because you're
just kind of seeing them as regular ass
people just doing their regular ass jobs
you know what I mean and it's just kind
of like they're
you know they're they're about to go
like waste a bunch of people like in
this thing and they're arguing about
foot massages like whether that counts
as like [ __ ] being like too intimate
we're talking about the metric system
they're talking about the Royale and all
that kind of stuff they're just talking
like about a bunch of stupid [ __ ] even
though they're about to go like kill
some [ __ ] you know what I mean
holy [ __ ]
uh since Wizkid says my dad's favorite
movie
yeah way to make us feel old well no I'm
just kidding yeah I was how old was I
when this movie came out I was I was in
my 20s I was
22. yeah I think I was 22 when this
movie came out yeah 22.
uh Maddie P said Inglorious Bastards is
amazing I liked Inglorious Bastards the
first time I watched it but when I
re-watched it it was a little too over
the top yeah I never didn't like it from
day one um because I remember seeing
that one in the theater I too crazy I
think that on Tuesday
um I think Danny asked us to do was it
Danny that asked us to do hateful eight
yeah so we'll probably do that I like
that one on Tuesday so yeah I remember
like I've seen that a couple of times
but it's been a while since I've seen I
haven't seen it as many times as I've
seen Pulp Fiction I've seen Pulp Fiction
Sam Jackson's in that one too so it's
Crustle that's right Crystal's in that
yeah pretzels in that yeah and uh what's
her name uh
uh how much people I'm getting old again
oh what's her name Jennifer Jason Lee
she's in it also
uh since whitskin said no no I showed it
to my dad oh okay so that's good I'm
just teasing you anyway he would have
loved you guys
oh what a nice thing
Ben says don't eat hamburgers for
breakfast
I mean
I kind of feel like the cons
breakfast food food is a fairly modern
concept I'll eat that I'll eat that food
any time of the day we eat it coming
back from the club
which I guess is that technically
breakfast I guess when you're drunk
you're gonna want [ __ ] breakfast food
man three o'clock in the morning
breakfast food [ __ ] right
well yeah I actually like I mean I love
breakfast food it's probably my favorite
thing but breakfast food is like a lot
better at three o'clock in the morning
my eggs and hash browns
hell yeah yeah see Ben says Hammond X is
okay hamburgers are not it's either so
much difference it's just in a different
configuration
yeah I mean I get it I get that we're
like not used to like eating a hamburger
for breakfast that is like a weird thing
to eat for breakfast but you know Mark
says breakfast food 24 7. I think
everywhere should have everywhere that
offers breakfast should have it all day
long yeah you know what I mean yeah Zach
said breakfast sandwiches yeah they're
the best all right so uh you you getting
like yeah I'm getting drunk you're
getting drunk well yeah you you got a
head start I'm Andrew yeah you get a
head start okay now uh tomorrow is
Monday which means it's a haunting
Mondays oh yeah yeah now do is there an
episode of I was trying to think of it
and I was looking at all the episode
lists and stuff is there a haunting
episode that has any jack [ __ ] to do
with Christmas or Yes No Maybe
I'm trying to think I was looking at the
episode guides and I'm like nothing's
like standing out like if anybody could
think of one but if anybody has one
because I think we've done all the ones
uh Daniel Rowling said the Unleashed
that's Christmas no but I mean maybe
because yeah he was asking about that
one before if we can't find like a
Christmasy one then we'll do the
Unleashed said White Witch
I mean we could stretch and make that
seem Christmasy just because it's
Christmasy week we don't have to do
Christmas I'm just saying I just
wondered if there was one that would
make it make it easier for us to pick
we'll do that one but we'll do yeah
we'll do the Unleashed because that's
another witchy one and we did a witchy
one last week so that should be that
should be fun
that should be fun uh all right so Tom's
drunk ass gotta go lay down yeah
yeah and then we gotta watch haunting
okay and I gotta take some notes on it
all right
be all right I'll be fine okay I'll be
fine Jen we'll just go ahead and shut it
down
okay shut that [ __ ] down watch I will
watch any haunting right okay
he's making fun of me that's okay I'm
not making funny don't get all don't get
all sensitive all right don't get all
sensitive uh all right so we will see
you guys again tomorrow for a haunting
Mondays so be sure to tune in for that
have a good rest of your weekend you
guys and we'll see you again tomorrow
good night